there's not even time to explain what
has happened so I'm gonna have to
explain when I get to the airport so
puppy get ready for your first ride I've
got a fanny pack are you ready for this
are you ready for this you're not ready
cuz I'm not ready I just need a document
what's happening right now
Oh
okay go buddy go buddy oh my gosh
come on your potty please thank didn't
love gets more water look at snooze you
lose II made it and he hasn't gone to
the bathroom yet so I'm a little
concerned that there may be some poo on
myself I'll let it blow me it's okay
definitely got it
I may have a few one hmm all right so
we're off to our annual family vacation
in North Carolina for the first time for
any Pittsburgh and then we're driving to
North Carolina with snoozy Busey sir I
don't know the previous bag that I had
fart was called we Isuzu sir barking
meow we do this is actually for Los
Angeles a Los Angeles based company
barking me out look how good you're
being
snoozin and lizard
throughout our first layover and I was
very good so far
bitingly
I see I saw an eyeball Jenna on behalf
of Southwest Airlines for the money
we're about to land he's been really
good
and keep checking on make sure he is
still alive
Manny hey honey
are you still alive oh yeah peas
stretching we made this Pittsburgh let's
take a little peek at snoozy losing
hey snoozer okay baby
yeah we've got the problem just like me
guess who made it home Maddy
what do you think you don't do you all
you look real cute he looks so much
older from his little haircut he doesn't
have a face look at you a wild wild look
at us so we made it home and now we're
on our way to North Carolina our family
trip there that we do every year and
this year we're bringing our little baby
carpet detail man oh boy he did such a
good job on the planes didn't even cry
or complain just slept go get it bring
back good wild in seven thirteen we are
on our way bad he's in his bag he's
already sleeping because we had him
pretty pretty rounded this morning
Manny in the bag
right now maddie is about to meet Belle
I'm nervous
are you never say no looks like there's
four bow because he's gonna be real
excited Maddie's taking taking potty in
the movie okay this is Justine's camera
oh my goodness for you excited to meet
your cut oh you're a mania oh so excited
I know I know I'm I'm a big deal
oh my goodness man hey hey hey buddy is
so big really nice hey this is wild
we're gonna play nice he's a big boy
when you're just little hey hey be nice
be nice good play good play I think he's
doing
so it's okay don't be scared
Piper knows someone wants to play is so
big
yeah oh you don't
okay me not just one so I though you'd
tell me why we're at our first
destination now first up you just had
lunch
you take a nice pee no no oh you and you
pee hey man hey man that shot this is
our first stop for gas potty we finally
made it to our vacation house where's
Maddy let's go see what we can see Maddy
come on let's go so we made it this
house is so pretty
come on bats here's your nice sleeping
quarters Maddy look at this castle that
we're in we're not gonna be able to take
him off the leash here because it's
he'll get lost
Maddie you're gonna have to be on the
leash the whole time in the house look
at that kitchen oh my goodness it's
gonna be awesome to hang a cooking video
in there cooking video fold a puppy yeah
look at you sniffing and sniffing I
guess that's it for our travels I'll see
you all this week the Mon fun family
vacation or meta go where'd he go
there's too many places for him to hide
Maddy
Matt Betty this is gonna be interesting
and this tastes like my morning's so
then we need to change one of your
answers if you think the pirate applause
yes yes vanilla you did